bâtonnier c'est à dire que se respecte
le patron de la saint-vincent d'une
façon ou d'une autre et c'est une
tradition qui guide du pays de trélon
temps chaque patient est une fierté le
jeu conclure oui c'est un mot dollar
pour un vigneron d'être désigné
bâtonnier c'est à dire maître de
cérémonie qu'à 70 cela n'arrive
généralement qu'une seule fois dans la
vie professionnelle
et c'est une vraie responsabilité
transmettre aux plus jeunes le respect
addition de la conf et
n'est pas nouvelle à
la saint vincent est effectivement
beaucoup plus que douteux
c'est d'abord une célébration religieuse
rien terme ans sans cesse renouvelé de
solidarité entre travailleurs de la
terre
à
m
pas plus tard que l'hiver dernière la
nos collègues vignerons du village avait
eu un accident de travail un samedi tous
les vignerons de la commune sont allait
lui tailler ses vignes ça c'est l'objet
de la confrérie saint vincent à la
saint-vincent il est aussi de coutume de
faire un voeu pour l'année nouvelle chez
les vignerons on a tous à peu près le
même souhait je souhaitais bien vendre
la 96 et avoir un 97 qui se présentera
bien pour assurer une continuité dans
les ventes également qu'on fasse une
bonne bande ans et puis que nos patrons
nous considèrent le mieux possible ce
qu'on souhaitait c'est avoir une si
belle récolte de 96 pour nous est très
belle donc on verra bien dans un an
après nous poser la même question
évidemment profite aussi de la
saint-vincent pour boire un peu et
décorer les meilleurs vendangeurs de
l'année précédente et puis quand les
virer les chambres seront estompées on
se rappellera que 7 590 elle s'est
déroulée sous un ciel clair et avec un
rayon de soleil c'est bon signe 3
vincent clerc est beau mais beaucoup de
vin dans le tonneau voilà